alors cette semaine au ciné c'est une
avant première exceptionnelle en
partenariat avec le lion's club pour
lutter contre l'illettrisme dimanche à
18h15 la projection du film rémi sans
famille avec daniel auteuil et le tarif
est exceptionnel parce qu'il ya une
partie des recettes qui sera versée à la
lutte contre l'illettrisme via le
lion's-club voilà et la semaine
prochaine le nouveau la nouvelle le
nouvel opus du festival saint quentin
festival du film documentaire donc à
plein de choses qui vont se dérouler du
28 novembre au 2 décembre notamment deux
soirées exceptionnelles lui le 29 à
l'ugc la soirée d'ouverture en présence
des frères bogdanoff et la soirée de
clôture qui se déroulera le 2 décembre à
partir de 16 heures au ciné cette avec
la projection de 16 levers de soleil qui
sera suivie de la remise du prix télé 78
du privé cinéma et du prix du public
parce que le public peut voter pour son
film préféré parmi sept documentaires en
compétition et tout cela sera suivi d'un
cocktail le plus chaleureux possible
nous le souhaitons bien sûr pour toutes
ces informations vous pouvez vous
inscrire et aussi pour ses soirées sur
le site ww point 50-1 point fr
[Musique]